David Kennedy who's the CEO of trusted
sec which is an internet security firm
he says that the site is a big old
hackers dream let's take a look you hit
the website we noticed a lot of the
performance issues that were happening
on the site and basically started just
poking and prodding a little bit looking
at the security and we found out that it
was pretty bad all around and there's
some things that couldn't even disclose
their because they were so critical
nature to you know public information
that we weren't evil even able to show
that when you say back well mean what
can you get at what type of information
could you get at as easily as you
suggest you can well everything from
hacking somebody's computer so when you
visit the website it actually tries to
hack your computer back all the way to
being able to extract email addresses
usernames you know first name last name
locations all those different things are
available now on the website okay well
that doesn't sound very good does it but
the question is who do we believe and
what do we believe I feel like every
time I hear another one of these things
because every two days something happens
now the sites getting hacked now the
site's not working at all now it's up
now 800 million people got on at once I
just don't know what to believe anymore
so before we get into the specifics of
what he said how have you decided what
you can and can't believe related to
this whole thing I just hope to stay
employed by the private sector so this
is everybody else's problem and not mine
because this sounds like a world-class
nightmare I have friends that got on
successfully they have a super low you
know copay and it's all good and they're
young healthy man and it's all good but
that's anecdotal III haven't seen any
evidence that anyone except my friend
chip is doing well with this site good
for chip yeah what do you think who do
you believe when it comes to in the
realm of having it every time you hear
something from any side of the aisle
just a font try and find their angle the
reason that they're saying what they're
saying if it's false so of course I go
into everything negatively like
everybody's lying so let's find out why
you're lying and then if it checks out
oh my bad you weren't lying so the first
thing I thought was having a chance for
this guy David Kennedy yeah David King
um first I look into his company trusted
sec what are they doing who they support
who supports them
track zactly right how often they appear
on certain networks uh you know where
they started with the background is
money where it comes from all that type
of stuff to see who they're who they
need to support or who supports them to
see who they need to serve to which I of
course like I said have no chance upon
who this guy was the first thing I
thought was who they get in and is the
lobbying firm is he have an interest
with uh with things with insurance
companies that want to keep things that
is for certain politicians as bigger
corporations I don't know right but
that's worth a look at intrust CNBC to
vet these people properly unfortunately
I think it may be only think to think in
all those that this is there's another
angle to the store we need to find out
from this expert not even say they're
coming from a bad place like his an
expert we don't know this works we need
a hacker gotta come in and tell us and
because it's a government website do
they not have to play by the same rules
that everybody else does so if we get
hacked they don't have to tell us right
well you know they were saying that even
yesterday the site was working at
something like ninety percent capacity
which if it was a private sector thing
you'd still get fired cuz amazon its
can't work at ninety percent capacity of
one out of every 10 people wasn't
getting service people would get fired
the only antic total thing that i can
tell you is that my sister actually
tried to sign up for obamacare and it
didn't work and then she started getting
spam emails about health insurance so
that does show you that there definitely
are some security thing with that i was
its what extent it's it's those time
things I voice told the story I ventured
into a Walmart last year and didn't buy
anything I was a my girlfriend she
bought things and I've strolled in
stroll back out within three hours I was
getting text messages about walmart then
and then and then take it I was like man
I was in you just in there you do it I
didn't use my card I didn't make a phone
call over there it's amazing so that so
I wanted to what degree things just kind
of know where you are i was talking with
michael shore before a beloved michael
shore tyt um but this I mean I'm not
itself Pacific's but it was a medical
conversation the next day we I started
getting uh sidebar on my computer
sidebar and adds about that can
specifically because i was asked never
heard that before please explain to me
what it was
a verbal conversation in person I mean
that's really coming and i love the same
really we're bus here at the right being
1984 yeah i haven't and i still have
well you're living it i can solve this
whole problem by the way all they need
to do is throw a dart at a map and pick
any high school pick a random kid out
and they will make a better website
wordpress cap it these are all things
that we all do in our sleep so if you
just want to have it done right with
with a little bit of security so you
don't get to hacked just as a
fourteen-year-old yeah so that goes to
what I've said every week that we've
done a story on this thing I want this
to work I believe we can have universal
healthcare like many other countries
have already but why does no one get
fired why doesn't anyone get fired
Sebelius anybody as I said last week a
janitor that works at the website
company why don't we fire anybody
everything in again I've worked in this
local government over the small county
jobs when I was trying to make some
money and broke as hell after college
but I'm this one things I'm begin to
believe about the red tape of government
when they swing Republican state
governors doesn't work government does
not do you think straight for like the
private sector think the private sector
can do the government I think can do is
fire someone that I think takes a
process it's hard to do its public when
it comes from this high office and ago
so now what are they gonna do next now
they gonna press covers but are they
gonna reveal some secrets or via some
information is someone gonna find out
more about them how many interviews they
gonna do I think there's so many extra
worries about it that they think it's
it's doubly worse yeah but it's the
mates but it's almost the nature of the
system I want to believe in Barack Obama
he's he's a cici's like a stand-up dude
and I would love for him to have a
closed-door meeting with all these fools
and be like you are making me look like
a punk ass chump yeah somebody fix this
instead of being like well you know give
it time now he sounds like a nap yes oh
ok that's a great segue so doesn't it
seem like he's lost some of his mojo
because of this i was watching the press
conference yesterday it's like remember
the hope in changing and we all were
like over the top it was like it was
really was really beyond what we were
all feeling with him and now it's like
he's droning on and it's like come
do you like why is any cracking heads
that's what I don't get that's the
question why is he crackin heads if he
is it just because he feels like you
know what I've done everything I can I'm
tired I want to take my water poodle or
whatever it is and just smoke some
cigarettes and ride the rest of this
thing out or does he really feel like
he's done everything is he can his hands
are tied and everyone in his own cabinet
is working against him is you know it is
everyone else the villain right or is he
just over it right or they don't even
tell him that's what it sounds like that
they don't really tell him when
something's really awry or a Miss it
doesn't even work its way up to him so
he can't be blamed and then we get pass
to set up and talk about it he comes
with the um I don't know and there comes
a time waster right and he can't say I
just don't know which they've released
in statements before he just didn't know
about certain things but um so when I
think when there's this much generated
there's always been deserves and so many
scandals in the tax in him that come up
empty right and was his look in this way
is because there's some merit to how bad
the website has launched now the mayor's
behind or the things that we're trying
to do with health care just provide
things for people that that that's the
positive part of it but the website self
it actually does suck so he actually
doesn't have waiters pull his mojo
through it right that's actually an
interesting point that maybe if the
Republicans hadn't been so crazed
attacking him on everything like
Benghazi and IRS things that quite
haven't fizzle you know ever have
fizzled out in a way that they would
have more of a legit voice to be
attacking him on this one do you think
at some point he just gets so fed up
with not knowing what to do that he's
gonna get up at the podium and just hold
up a picture of his birth certificate be
like I have literally nothing else to
give well that the thing maybe he shot
his load early so to speak and should
have been waiting down the birth of the
other so one of the things I think is
really interesting is you know the whole
premise of Obamacare's that you need
young healthy people to sign up because
that will keep the premiums low so they
say that it they need about forty
percent of healthy people between 18 and
35 to get this thing to function
properly but when you hear about the
hacking in this kinda stuff that to me
goes to what young people know about
more which makes it seem like young
people are even going to do this less so
then that that even hurts it more so is
this just like this endless double-edged
sword we got on I I think you really hit
the nail on the head i think it's old
people trying to play a young people's
game and
we're going to do something this
newfangled thing called a website and
they can't even get the basics down
right and a sophisticated youngsters I
don't want anything to do with it
because we know better yeah so like I
said they should just pick you know some
whatever grab a kid from MIT that's what
they do that's why they're there and let
him figure it out let her figure it out
but watching these people putz around is
really not helping that so final thought
on this so how much of this because I
know your conspiracy theorist how much
it is do you do you think could be done
intentionally that hackers are
intentionally doing this I don't know
their political affiliation but let's
say let's say something like anonymous
not necessarily anonymous are actually
attend intentionally attacking the site
because they want this thing to fail
well I don't know that some of the
aspects of what's happening is it that
is their finding that is getting cyber
attack that is getting hit from all
sides or this that when people test it
we're finding the holes in it so it's
it's right I just think it's both it's
partly it's not working it's just when
I'm not working they already did they
can't get the payments if you pay the
brain doesn't go to insurance companies
yeah I have a picture of the guys in in
DC in general they're all the guys know
what they're doing right but then
there's the reality of their staff for
younger people so David sucked into the
machine so much that they don't they
forgot what normal life is like for 26
to 32 year old maybe I don't know but
that again you have to reach outside of
it and get one of these guys in like I
need you to find out what's going on
with this before we find out what's
going on this because but the problem is
it's hard to relinquish that control I
think especially firm the higher-ups to
control people like you know I'm an
elected official you know who I am yeah
then once all of a sudden there's a
problem everybody back away back away
Boogaloo and then President Obama gets
up there doesn't it so if they're trying
to protect them they're doing a hell of
a bang up job because he gets up there
he doesn't know what the hell he's
talking about because nobody wants to
tell the boss that whatever they did
they [ __ ] up yeah and on that note
would you guys just fix this freaking
thing so the people that want it to work
like the three of us would feel better
about it we wouldn't have to do segments
like this okay
you